all right we are going to continue our
discussion of extrema graph theory last
time we discussed what happens when we
exclude a triangle or more generally a
creek and we wish to find a graph that
maximizes the number of edges and at the
end of the lecture I stated the theorem
of error stone and shamone which which
test recall that if you have a fixed H
and I wish to understand the maximum
number of edges in an N vertex graph
that is H free so remember this
definition this is the maximum number of
edges in an N vertex H free graph so we
are going to be looking at this quantity
in the next few lectures
so the Adderstone Shmuel image theorem
tells us that perhaps quite surprisingly
this quantity is largely governed by the
chromatic number of H even though H
itself might be quite involved so if you
knew the chromatic number you already
know a lot of information about the
growth rate of this function in
particular as long as H is not bipartite
so that the chromatic number is at least
3 we already know the first word
asymptotics from the error Stoneman
image theorem however when H is
bipartite
so that the chromatic number is exactly
two then the theorem tells us only that
this quantity is little o of N squared
which is some useful information but it
doesn't tell us the whole story in the
next several lectures I want to explore
what more can we say about this quantity
here for bipartite graphs H and it turns
out that there's a lot that we do not
know there are lots of open problems in
this area having to do with trying to
pin down the growth rate of this
function in particular for bipartite
graphs there's a bipartite graph that
plays a somewhat special role namely the
complete bipartite graph so KST in the
complete bipartite graph with s vertices
on one side and P vertices on the other
side so this is a very nice bipartite
graph and just to understand the
extremal number for this graph is a
famous open problem in this area and it
has the name of 0 and K which problem
which is to determine or estimate the
extremal numbers for these complete
bipartite graphs ok so i'll tell you
pretty much all we know about this
problem there are some interesting
things but we do not know all that much
you know every bipartite graph is a
subset it's a sub graph of such a
complete bipartite graph so every
bipartite h is a soft graph
of some KST and we know that if H is a
sub graph of this KST then the extremal
number for H if your graph is H free
then automatically has to be KST 3 so
there's this bound between these two
extremal numbers so in particular if you
have some upper bound on case T's then
you have some upper bound on bipartite
graphs although for specific bipartite
graphs each maybe we can do better than
using the spam and we'll see examples of
that later in the course as well okay so
what can we say about the extremal
numbers of these ksps and so the most
important theorem in this area of this
problem is a result due to Kaveri show
Shantaram so the kaveri shows Terron
theorem tells us that for every fixed
integers s and t as a most t there
exists some constant C such that the
extremal number is upper bounded by
something which is on the order of n to
the 2 minus 1 over s gives you some
upper bound showing you that it has not
only sub-quadratic but there's a gap
from 2 in the exponent now in
combinatorics SS with many fields of
mathematics it can be somewhat
intimidating to newcomers when you see a
lot of names or every germs seems to be
half named after a string of
mathematicians know some of humor
I heard of some me not and Aguas and it
may be difficult to remember who is who
and what is what
I think this term has a very nice way to
remember which is that it's a term about
K STS and this is the KSR T theorem okay
all right so this is the KSR T theorem I
want to begin by showing you how to
prove the KS t theorem but the proof is
we are a nice not too difficult double
counting argument and then show you some
applications so let's prove this theorem
and it's by a double counting argument
what are we going to count well let's
start with the object that we're working
with so there's going to be a graph G
that has n vertices and edges and KS T 3
and let's count the number of stars K s
1 in this graph G so we're counting
configurations like that do an upper
bound and a lower bound on one hand so
let's start with the upper bound I want
hand every subset of s vertices in the
graph G has at most t minus 1 comma
neighbors
because if they have T common neighbors
then you get a KS t so that's one down
on the other hand let's see what happens
to the number of common neighbors if you
knew that this graph has a lot of edges
so the number of stars well I can
calculate this quantity explicitly by
running over all the vertices of G for
each vertex look at its neighborhood and
choose s vertices from its neighborhood
so for each beep I need to find a sub
set of s vertices from its neighborhood
by convexity I can lower bound the sum
by the average in some sense because
okay let me first write down the
expression so I can do a convex the
argument that gives me this lower bound
here I'm using abusing notation somewhat
and writing binomial coefficients with a
real entry on top where I mean the
expression as you would expect treating
the sky is a polynomial in X and the key
fact we're using here is that this
function here is convex for X at least
and minus one so in particular if you
think about this function here we have a
lot of zeros and then it becomes convex
afterwards so you can even think of
extending this function is zero to the
left of em -
so this is a convex function and you can
apply convexity to reduce this
inequality but you know the sum of the
degrees that's just essentially twice I
mean that is to twice the number of
edges so we have this expression right
here so you have an upper bound on the
number of s stars coming from KST
freeness and lower bound on the number
of s stars coming from just having lots
of edges and applying convexity okay
putting these two things together we
find that there's this inequality here
here we are thinking of s and TS fixed
and we are trying to understand how m
and n depend on each other as they get
large so it will be helpful to use the
asymptotics that and choose s grows like
and to the s divided by s factorial for
fixed s so looking at that expression
and applying this asymptotics to both
sides we have this inequality here so
I've eliminated s factorial from both
sides okay so now rearrange clean things
up we find the following upper bound on
M the number of edges in G
and that's the expression so for fixed
SNT a gross like n to the 2 minus 1 over
s any questions yeah so so the questions
were the right side of inequality which
inequality this one here right so here
we are counting the number of K as once
so here I am so upper lower bounding the
number of KS once using what we derived
earlier yes right the question is do we
care that s is less than equal to T in
the argument the argument doesn't care
but of course if you want the better
asymptotics for fixed s and T as n gets
large you should take s to be less than
equal to T question what happens when T
equals to 1 well that's a great question
I'll leave you to think about it if you
have if you know that your graph has
maximum degree at most T what can you
tell me about a number of edges in the
graph
okay any more questions
okay well come back to this theorem in
fact this will occupy us for at least a
couple of lectures basically it's this
theorem kite and it is conjectured to be
although that is a major open problem
extreme of graph theory
we only know a small number of values
well for most values of s and T in
particular one s and P are both equal to
four we do not know if this bound is
tight but there are some values of s and
T for which we do know that it is tight
for example 2 & 2 3 & 3 4 & 7 s and if T
is really really large and I will show
you some constructions later on creating
graphs G that are KST free for those
parameters that matches this KST bound
up to a constant factor yes right so the
question is for a fixed value of s is
there some bound on T for which we get
equality cases there is a conjecture
that this bound is sharp up to a
constant factor for every s and T but we
only know how to prove that conjecture
and I will explain I will tell you much
more about that later on when P is much
larger compared to s there's there are
lots of unexplored territory on this
problem any more questions ok before
diving into the curve average shorter on
theorem further I just want to show you
some neat applications
and I want to begin with a geometric
application there's a classic problem
asked by elders back in the 40s called
the unit distance problem which asks
what is the maximum number of unit
distances maximum number of unit
distances formed by n points in the
plane let me give you some examples if
you have three points you put them in an
equilateral triangle and all three
distances are unit great if you have
hope four points you cannot place them
so that all 6 distances are units if
you're staying the plane so the best
thing you can do is something like this
okay so I'm drawing all the edges that
are unit distances if you have one more
point turns out that's the best thing
you can do with five points with six
points there are some more possibilities
let me draw for you some possibilities
you can extend the previous
configuration by adding more triangles
and there are many different ways that
you can attach an extra triangle
there's actually one more way to do it
with six points namely I can put them
like a projection of a prism so all of
these configurations have the maximum
number of unit distances obtained if you
draw six points if you draw seven points
turns out this is the best way to do it
okay so you can go on for a while and
people have okay so you can try to
tabulate for every and what's the
maximum number of unit distances you can
generate having n points in the plane
and the question is what is the answer
for n points and it turns out for this
problem and for many problems like it in
combinatorics you can have a lot of fun
with playing with small examples but
they are often misleading it doesn't
really tell you what the overall
structure should be like and it turns
out this is a major open-palm for which
we do not understand what the structure
is like for large values of n so think
and large what are some possible ways to
generate many unit distances yep great
so one way is to draw lots of triangles
so extend this figure forward okay so
let's do that well actually let me give
you something even simpler to begin with
I can just put the endpoints on the line
equal spaced okay I get n minus 1
distances I minus 1 unit distances if I
put them like that how many units
distances do I get
all right two times n minus one so each
new point gives you two extra new
distances and you can try to think about
how to do better if you follow that
sequence of examples maybe you're
limited to such ideas yes you are not
allowed to put in the same points in the
same place that's a great question but
you're not allowed to put points in the
same place yes so so I didn't quite
understand so you say if you put huh yep
ah so you want to take this example and
keep translating in some directions I
think you would run out of room pretty
quickly
hmm I say you want to take this
configuration and translate it in some
unit direction well then you double the
number of points but you don't actually
increase the number of unit distances or
that much okay so the suggestion is we
take some configuration we take some
configuration let's say this graph G and
I form two copies of G by translating G
in some unit Direction some generic unit
Direction okay great so what happens to
the number of vertices so n goes to 2m
and the number of edges goes from m2 to
M plus n all right okay great so if you
do that what do you get and log n okay
that's much better than before okay
good very nice yes
Oh
right so there are suggestions to start
with some graph G and then I'm replacing
so let's as an example look at that one
and I'm replacing each vertex here by an
equilateral triangle but I want to
maintain the same unit distance right so
the huh it's this similar to taking this
graph G and then translating it in two
different directions that form an
equilateral triangle I think it's yeah
so it's a very similar idea and maybe
you do a little bit better in terms of
constants okay yeah all are great
suggestions I'm actually this is this is
really nice two times and you want to
make a constant correction okay let me
just do that any more suggestions okay
yeah all of this is really nice so so
let me tell you what is the best
construction that people are aware of
and this is a construction due to air
dish and the idea is to think big not
build from small examples so what air
dash did is to consider a square grid
root n by root n okay when I see
something that's do then it's non
integer just think round down to the
lowest to the nearest integer I have a
square grid now if you take the these
distances as unit distances okay you get
something which is linear in n so you
don't gain that much but you can take
any specific distance as your unit
distance so what we can do is take a
distance that is represented many times
in this grid so let's take the unit
distance to be a distance root R where R
is some integer that can be represented
as a sum of two squares in many
different ways so for example
so we can take some are so that it has
many appearances and if you know some
elementary number theory then you might
know that the best way to do this is to
take R to be a product of primes that
are one more form in any case you can do
this and you can use some analytic
number theory to calculate if you choose
the best possible value of R how many
distances do you get so that calculation
was done and it turns out you get n
raised to the power of 1 plus some
constant C over log log and you know
distances so this is better than the
constructions we've seen before so what
can we say about this problem so this is
a construction well then you want to
understand some upper bounds what can we
say about upper bounds to this prompt
and let me show you a fairly easy upper
bound which can be deduced very quickly
from the curve re shows Toronto that
every set of n points in the plane has a
most on the order of n to the three
halves
unit distances so not quite
this bount but it's some time right so
the trivia upper bound is and choose
tube it's much better than a trivial
upper back so here's the proof so let's
consider the unit distance graph which
is basically the graphs I've been
drawing where you have the vertices the
points and I join an edge between two
vertices if and only if their distance
is exactly one I claim this graph is k23
free why is that because if you have two
points what are their common neighbors
their common neighbors must all be a
distance one from each of the two points
so they're common neighbors must lie on
the intersections of the unit circles
centered at these two points and they
meet at most two points so it's k23 free
therefore the caballos quran theorem
tells us that the number of edges in
this Jeep is upper bounded by n to the
three half and that's it it gives you
some upper bound any questions
so it's an application to of Torah shows
Turin where we design a graph there has
to be K two three free and the extremal
number tells us some information about
this graph what is the best found out we
know so it turns out we do know how to
do a little bit better but not anywhere
close to what we believe to be the truth
so the current best bound is on the
order of n to the 4/3 and we'll actually
see a proof of this later in the course
once we've developed something called
the crossing numbers inequality so
there's also a very short very neat
proof
I want to tell you about another problem
which looks superficially similar and
also a really interesting geometric
problem and this is the address distinct
distances problem which asks for the
maximum number of distinct distances
among end points in the plane so the
minimum thank you the minimum number of
distinct distances as a maximum will be
very easy again you have lots of
examples in fact you can look at
basically all the examples so we've
given earlier I mean these two problems
are very much related to each other you
see if you want lots of repeat distances
or if you want
very few distinct distances right they
they seem like they're very much related
and of course you can also write down an
inequality that relates the two of them
because the number of distinct distances
is at least and choose two divided by
the number of the maximum number of unit
distances
in other words the number of distances
that can be repeated in any single
configuration okay right so each of the
examples I just erased so for example if
you put points on the line you have n
minus 1 to sting distances and we
already saw the square grid so that
might be a good candidate to look at as
well and there it takes some more number
theory to figure out how many distinct
distances are they are and this roughly
corresponds to the number of yeah so the
the number of integers that can be
written as a sum of two squares and so
this has been calculated and the result
is n divided by square root of log n so
that's the order okay and air -
conjecture that this example should be
more or less the best you can do so
these palms look very similar but
actually this problem here was solved in
a spectacular fashion about a decade ago
by an important paper of Guth and cats
so Larry goose is in our department and
they showed that every set of n points
in the plane generates at least on the
order of n over log n distinct distances
so not quite what aired is conjectured
but nearly there and in fact all the
previous results were much worse so they
were off in the exponent but this one
more or less got to the truth so this is
a very sophisticated result that used
lots of amazing techniques ranging from
the polynomial method in combinatorics
to some algebraic geometry and that's I
just want to mention it for cultural
value ok any questions yes yeah so for
the unit distance problem and actually
for the distinct distances problem the
question is what was believed to be the
what is believed to be the bound and
that it's the square grid all right so
maybe you can do slightly better but it
is conjecture that you cannot do much
better let's say by more than a constant
factor compared to the square grid yes
sorry so this is Nets cats he's at
Caltech okay I want to take a short
break now and when we come back I want
to show you some ways to generate lower
bounds to the extremal number in the
kaveri shows tauren theorem we
understood some upper bounds for the
extremal number so I want to turn our
attention now to lower bounds which
means constructing in some sense graphs
that have lots of edges at the same time
being KSP 3 there are many classes of
construction so there are several
techniques for doing this and I want to
introduce you to some of these
techniques and the first one comes from
the probabilistic method where we use a
randomized construction by taking the
graph at random modifying it a little
bit in a way that's to our desire this
method is very powerful it is very
general it is applicable in a lot of
situations but unfortunately for the
problem of getting tight bounds it is
really it really allows you to get tight
bounds so it is very robust
but somehow it's often not sharp and
another class of constructions that are
algebraic all the sharp examples come
from algebraic constructions and there
were able to use some nice ideas from
from algebra from algebraic geometry to
get tight constructions and you can
wonder is there some way to combine the
best of both worlds and it turns out
this was a important recent development
that was found just several years ago
where one can combine ideas from the two
and obtain a randomized algebraic
construction
and that leads to a new source of
constructions for large H free graphs
with many edges okay so the plan is to
show you how these constructions work
okay first let's begin with random nice
constructions as I mentioned this
construction is very general it's very
robust and we can use it to obtain H
free graphs for every graph H of course
when H is not bipartite then we saw from
the current graph that that's pretty
much the right thing to do so you should
think about bipartite graphs H so fix
the graph H with at least two edges
otherwise prom is trivial the claim is
that there is some constant C such that
for every n you think of n is being
large there exists an H free graph and
vertices and having lots of edges and we
will show that you can obtain the
following number of edges so two -
number of vertices of H - 2 divided by
the number of edges of H minus 1 okay
don't worry about this expression in the
exponent it will come out of the proof
in other words the extremal number is at
least this quantity here
all right how good this is found some
scary-looking expression in the exponent
so let me just give you some special
cases for comparison to the calvario
Sturm theorem for KS TS the bound this
construction gives you a lower bound
which is of the form n to the 2 minus s
plus t minus 2 divided by s t minus 1 so
i use this symbol this bigger turtle to
denote dropping constant factors in
particular setting s and P to be the
same we find that the KS s extremal
number is lower bounded by this quantity
here okay so how does that compared to
Guevara shows toro in Kavala shows
tauren we saw that KS s is at most 2 to
the n to the 2 minus 1 over s so there's
a bit of a gap and in particular even
for 2 & 2 these results tell you a lower
bound on the order of n to the 4/3 an
upper bound on the order of 3 hi I'm
just doing this explicitly to show you
that even in sometimes the simplest case
there is a gap between these two bounds
later on we'll see a construction that
shows that the right-hand side is tight
right so this is the truth the
randomized construction gives you
something but it doesn't give you the
truth on the other hand I want you to
notice that if he gets very long
as a function of s this exponent here
approaches one over s as T goes to
infinity so for very large values of T
at least in the exponent it's not that
far off although you never get the right
exponent for any specific SNP okay so
this is some limitation of the
randomized method but I know it's very
robust and in fact you can use this
result to do to bootstrap it to a
slightly better one for some grass h so
for example one might do better by
replacing this H by a subgraph but
because if you have a subgraph H Prime
and you construct your G to be H Prime
free then it is automatically H free but
maybe this theorem actually gives you a
better construction when restricted to H
Prime and what can you do better well
you can do better if H prime is such
that whatever the quantity that comes up
in the exponent so let me write it like
this is superior to the exponent you
would obtain by just looking at H so let
me get the name to this notion here so
let me call the two density of the graph
to be whatever quantity here that would
be the maximum if you allow to pass down
two sub graphs the two density of a
graph H so to know that in literature
often s M sub two to be the maximum
where you allowed
to look at subgraphs let's say on least
three vertices to avoid degeneracies
this ratio that comes up in the
expressions so then the theorem that
construction there implies that the
extremal number is at least not just the
expression I've written but maybe
sometimes you can do slightly better by
passing to a sub graph so let me give
you a concrete example suppose my H yes
this graph here so you can run the
calculation and find what these numbers
are so the number of vertices edges and
this ratio here to be five vertices
eight edges and 7/3 and the idea here is
that it's more helpful or so I want to
create something which is a ch3 but
dense things are easier to avoid all
right so if I have something which is
some fairly dense core that's easier to
avoid so maybe it's better to instead of
looking at a whole H look at this k4 so
if you can avoid k4 of course you avoid
H and maybe it's easier to just avoid k4
and not worry about some of the extra
decorations so if you look at this H
Prime and go through the parameters you
find that it is like that
and it is somewhat denser in this sense
compared to looking at whole graphic so
you can improve on this theorem for some
graphs H where you can pass to a denser
core okay any questions so far
yes questions why is this measure called
the two density so that's a named
covering literature party has to do with
these extra ratios so there are other
notions of densities that actually we'll
see later on
so this term will only see today so it's
more of an ad-hoc term for the purpose
of this course later on we'll see
notions of density that are more
relevant for our discussions any more
questions okay so let me show you how to
prove this theorem
the proof is very intuitive the idea is
you take something ID random and then
you fix it that's it let's consider a
random graph the address when a random
graph so whenever say random graph I
almost always refer to this one here and
the address when a random graph is
obtained by considering n vertices and
each edge each possible edge appearing
independently and uniformly with
probability P and we're going to decide
this P later on so let me not tell you
what P is for now I'm interested in
avoiding H so this random graph might
have some copies of H let me count the
number of copies of H we can compute the
expected number of copies of H by
linearity of expectations for every
possible placement look at what's the
probability that that placement
generates an H namely look at all
different possibilities for choosing the
possible vertices of H I need to divide
it by a factor that accounts for the
number of automorphisms of age but just
a constant factor don't worry about it
and for each of these possible
placements H appears with probability
exactly P - the number of edges of H
just by linearity of expectations and I
can upper bound this quantity very
crudely by e to the number of edges of H
times n which is the number of vertices
of G raised to number of vertices of H
on the other hand I also want a graph G
that has lost
of edges because that's what we're
trying to do or trying to generate a
graph with lots of eight edges that's h3
so the number of edges of G that's also
easy to compute it's a binomial
distribution and has expectation P times
and choose two and basically I want this
quantity to be much larger than that
quantity so I choose an appropriate P
namely by comparing these two quantities
and choose P to be let's say 1/2 the
half is not important times n to the D
of H minus 2 divided by e of H minus 1
the exponent comes out of comparing
these two expressions so you see a 1 and
a 2 once you have this peep see that the
number which is the difference so take
the number of edges of G minus the
number of copies of H I know the
expectation of both I can look at their
difference with this value of P we find
that it is at least half of the number
of edges so on expectation you don't
lose too much so piece chosen so that
this inequality is true right so you set
what P is we find that this content here
is at least some constant times n to the
2 minus V of H minus 2 divided by P of H
minus 1 we're still working with a
random graph and we know that this
quantity here is on expectation at least
that number not too small
therefore
there exists some instance in this
randomness some G such that the quantity
above for the specific random instance
is at least its expectation so this
gives us a graph G which on one hand has
lots of edges but also has very few
copies of H relative to the number of
edges so we can now get rid of all the
copies of H by removing one edge from
each copy of H in G to remove all copies
of H and now we obtain an H free graph
how many edges are there in this graph
but we removed at most one edge for each
copy of H so the number of edges is at
least this quantity here which is what
we wrote
and that's it right so now we've
obtained our graph on n vertices with
lots of edges with the claim bound
that's a ch3 so this is the
probabilistic method that you start with
something random you try to fix it and
this method sometimes has the name of
the alteration method and it has a very
important idea and one of the key ideas
in the probabilistic method which I
encourage you to go and learn more about
will also see this method later on when
we discuss the randomized algebraic
construction so I mean so questions yeah
the question is one is what do I mean by
the number of copies of H I mean every
instance of H you see so they could be
intersecting I'm not asking for
destroying copies yeah so a complete
graph on n vertices has n choose 3
triangles any more questions ok so now
we've seen that the probabilistic method
gives you you know some bound and it's
not too hard to apply but it doesn't
give you the right bound it doesn't give
you the truth so now I want to show you
a different type of constructions namely
algebraic instructions that do allow you
to get the truth but they work in a only
a small number of cases so it's more
magical but they work better when the
magic happens
so let's discuss algebraic constructions
in particular I want to show you how to
obtain the tight bound on the extremal
number for k2 - namely a four cycle so
this is a result due to elder's rainy
and shoosh and tells us that the
extremal number for k2 to is at least
one half basically up to asymptotics
times n to the three-halves
actually if you look at the constant
that came out of the proof of the Cova
shows tour on there it is also one half
so as a corollary we see that the
extremal number it's like that okay so
this is one of extremely few cases where
we know the extremal number so well so
the constant if you go back to the proof
of Kovar we chose to round you see that
the constant actually there is one half
okay so I want to construct for you a
graph that has no four cycles and has
lots of edges so that's the name of the
game and I'll describe this graph for
you explicitly so this graph has a name
it's called a polarity graph
let's suppose that n is a number such
that one bigger than this number is a
square of a prime so construction will
use some prime some finite fields I'll
explain a bit if n it's not of this form
then you can change n to a number very
close to of this form and everything
will be okay the graph will be
constructed as follows the vertex set
will be the plane over FP let's remove
the origin so has n points exactly and
the edges are such that I put an edge
between X Y and a beam if and only if
the equation ax plus py equals to one
holds and this equation is meant to be
read in FP so that's the graph that's an
explicit description of this graph so I
need to show you two things one that has
lots of edges the claim number of edges
and - it has no four cycles ok so let's
start with not having four cycles so why
is it K - 2 3 ok what would a K - to be
so let's consider two points
so and I want to understand the number
of common neighbors of these two points
well look at the description for the
edges what are the neighbors well the
neighbors correspond to solutions to
this system of equations and the basic
claim is that there's at most one
solution X Y basic back in linear
algebra you have to be slightly careful
in case a B is a multiple of a prime B
prime but actually in that case you have
no solutions anyway okay the second
claim then is that this graph has lots
of edges well actually that's not too
hard to show either so I claim that
every vertex has degree
okay so what's how many edges come out
of every vertex I'll give you a a comma
B so how many x comma y satisfy that
equation up there basically for one case
one of X in a and B is nonzero so for
whatever value off so let's say a is
nonzero then for whatever value of y you
set I can find a unique X that solves
the equation I have to be slightly
careful because I don't allow loops in
my graph so I might lose one edge
because of that in any case every vertex
has degree exactly key or P minus one so
just solve that equation in x and y
so the P minus one comes from no loops
therefore up the number of edges is
equal to the claimed belt okay so this
finish is the proof in case when n has
that special number theoretic form but
we can extend to all values of n like
this if n doesn't have that form then I
can take a prime P may not necessarily
be exactly satisfying that inequality
but I can always take a prime pretty
close to it so I can always take a prime
which is up to a negligible
multiplicative error what I want and
then we use and such that P squared
minus 1 is at most and and use the
compulsion struction and add isolated
vertices to finish the job to get
exactly n vertices and the reason that I
can always take a prime very close to it
is because there's a theorem in number
theory that tells us that and large
enough I can always find the prime which
is slightly less than n but no more than
negligible multiplicative factor off the
best result of this form is just I'm
just telling you something number three
for cultural reasons so
best result of the storm is due to Baker
Harmon pence so this is the question
regarding how large can gaps between
prime speed so you might know the the
rich later them that he'll see there's
always a prime between N and 2n so what
about between and an M plus 210 actually
we don't know that right so the best
ways out of the form is that there's
always a prime for n sufficiently large
there exist a prime between n - n 2 the
exponent 0.5 to 5 and n any case this
number here whatever it is is not all N
and that's enough for that's enough for
all purpose okay so it's suffices to
look at end of a special number
theoretic form that where you're allowed
to use Prime's so that's the
construction there let me show you a
interpretation of that construction
which i think is maybe helpful to to
think about and that's that you can view
it as the incidence graph between points
and lines in projective space in
projective plane so I start with a
projective plane
okay so I can view a bipartite version
of that construction it can be viewed as
the point line incidence graph of a
projective plane over a finite field and
by this I mean put as one vertex set the
points of the projective plane and on
the other side of lines and I put in an
edge between a point and a line if and
only if the point lies on the line so
you can do this more explicitly in
coordinates if you view them points and
lines as coordinates and so the equation
for getting point to be on the line is
like that so now why is there no four
cycle a four cycle would correspond to
two points lying on two different lines
which is not possible in this geometry
right so that's the reason for for that
construction up there
so no two points in two lines okay any
questions about this polarity
constructions yep
right questions why is it called a
polarity construction so it relates
points and their Polar's which are lines
yep okay the question is has to do with
a number of vertices here it's true here
I double the number of vertices and so I
don't get that constant there but what
that graph up there that's not a
bipartite graph it is identifying the
points and the lines and overlaying the
two parts into one but if you don't care
about the constants this graph here may
be conceptually easier to think about
yes great question can you generalize
this polarity graph to K 3 3 and higher
so that's what we're about to do next
okay so for K 3 3 what can you do
so the main observation here is that two
lines intersecting at most one point
right but there are other geometric
facts of that form so we're going to use
one of them to get a 2/3 free graph and
this construction is due to brown that
the extremal number for K 3 3 is also at
least factor 1/2 minus 2 0 1 times ok so
now what's the exponent what is
predicted by cavora shows Terron is 2
minus 1/3 and brown obtains the correct
exponent it turns out this is also the
right constant this 1/2 although it
doesn't follow from the khawarij shows
tour under my stated one needs to do a
little bit extra work but it turns out
it is true that this is also the correct
constant and that's actually pretty much
all the cases where we know the correct
constant and there are other cases where
we know the correct exponent but these
things tend to be
hard to come by okay so let me show you
how to construct the scrap so it's based
on a similar idea as the polarity graph
it has some more technicalities so I'm
not going to do the full proof and just
give you the sketch as earlier I'm using
the same trick we can assume that n has
a special form here let me assume that N
is a cube of a prime I'm going to put AZ
edges so first the vertices of my graph
are going to be points in the earth I'm
playing over FP previously the lines had
to do was previously the edges had to do
with lines and now let's use spheres so
the edges had the form where I joined
two vertices like this if and only if
there it's not really a distance but
it's something that looks like the
equation of a sphere where u is some
fixed
nonzero element of FP you may have to be
somewhat careful in choosing this you
but let me not worry too much about it
so you fix some so-called distance even
though it's not a distance and I joined
the vertices whenever they satisfy that
equation having that you know not
distance okay what's the intuition here
the intuition is that I want to avoid
okay so how do I know that this graph
has no k33 well first let's think about
what happens in real space so intuition
in in the real space well here I have
this graph that's let's say the unit
distance graph in r3 so the neighborhood
of each point is a unit sphere and what
I want to know is that if you have three
spheres three units spheres
how many common intersection points can
they have two spheres intersect in a
circle and that circle cannot lie on the
third circle that you should think about
so that circle intersects the third
circle you know most two points so three
units spheres at most two common points
and so the unit distance graph in r3 is
K 3 3 3 that entire argument even though
I expressed it geometrically it's an
algebraic argument you can write down
equations on intersections between two
spheres it's the intersection of the
sphere with its coaxial plane I have a
couple of these coaxial planes that get
your coaxial line that line has to
intersect the sphere in and most two
points you should actually do this
algebra if you want to do the proof
because they're funny things that
can happen you'll find our fuels for
example maybe the sphere contains the
line but you choose your parameters
correctly and these things don't happen
and that's the intuition and if you
actually work this out you find that
this graph here is indeed K 3 3 3 ok so
I'm skipping the details but you should
do the algebra if you want to have a
proof on the other hand it also has lots
of edges and that's basically the same
reason as before but I can count the
number of edges by fixing some x y&z and
look at how many ABC satisfy that
equation and that's again something that
needs to be checked but point is that
this graph so every vertex has either P
squared ok so it has close to P squared
degree so lots of edges and combining
with basically the same ideas as before
you get the construction any questions
ok so where can we go from here to
construct the k22 by the way if you
construct a 2 to 3 the same construction
works for K to 3 free it's K 2 to 3 then
it's also K to 3 free K 2 for free here
likewise this is also K 3 for free ok so
now what about higher KS T's and you
might think well let's take these
geometric objects and try to extend them
further but that actually seems kind of
difficult we do not really know how to
do it we do not know how to obtain a
construction which is of this form that
works for K 4
in fact there even some evidence that
that might be impossible as I mentioned
k4 4 is a major open problem it has an
open problem to determine the order of
the extremal number of k4 for playing
any case this construction this idea of
using algebraic constructions is very
enlightening that we should look at ways
to get large KST free graphs by coming
up with clever algebraic constructions
and next time I will show you a couple
of very nice ideas where you can get you
can come up with a different kind of
algebraic construction which has some
superficial similarities to what we've
seen today but that's really of a
different nature so next time we will
see the following theorem which is
obtain a sequence of two papers Union of
authors along colar Brownian double that
shows that if P is much larger than s so
s minus 1 factorial plus 1 then
the extremal number for KST is on the
same order as the upper bound determined
in the cavalry shows Turin theorem just
to be more explicit about what this s
and P are if you plug in what's the
smallest T that this theorem gives for
various values of s find 2 2 & 3 3 and
the next one is 4 7 and then it gets
worse from there
so these constructions are based on I
mean there are algebraic instructions
and so we'll see you next time